the viral success story of Matt Rife can
be traced back to two main factors being
stage time and crowd work most comedians
begin their careers getting on stage for
the first time in their early 20s if
they're lucky and usually have about 10
years of learning the ropes and
perfecting their crafts through many ups
and downs leading up to hitting their
stride as a known comedian sometime in
their 30s then farther developing from
there to hopefully be playing the
biggest venues possible by their 40s
Matt Rife did things differently his
stand-up career began at the young age
of 15. this unbelievably Early Head
Start is what allows Matt to be
seemingly way ahead of schedule at age
27. most Comics his age have a few years
of experience Max under their belt but
Matt Rife has 12